COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY SECOND.
.
PLEASE ADVISE ON AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS
GREEN BAY. HAS ALSO BEEN
TELEVISED.
A MAN OF SECTOR PEACEFUL COOLEY
HERE CUNNINGHAM HERE ALLEN
GROWTH
CARILLO.
CERVANTES HERE FRIEDMAN GRAYSON.
AS AREA SOLACE PRESENT. WALDRON.
WE HAVE A BOND WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA. IS
OUR MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA
MOVE THANK GOD MOVE OVER SALAS
SECOND WHEN MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
AMENDED SECTOR FISCAL COOLEY AYE
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE
CUNNINGHAM AYE ALLEN BROUGH
CARILLO.
CORREO AYE CERVANTES CHAU
CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE NOSE AREA SOLACE.
SOLIS AYE WALDRON TIME WALDRON
AYE.
THE MOST IS PASSED AND THAT
CONCLUDES WORKABLE SPREADING
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'VE